RAV I know one guy that you and I I
would say trusted fairly intimately over
the last couple years on most things was
Sam Harris and Sam Harris has had I
think just some a series of big I would
say political blunders something to that
effect and he was on a podcast recently
talking about how we should really only
listen to experts and I thought it was
rather enlightening take a look
there's we're swimming in a sea of
misinformation where you've got people
who are moving the opinions of millions
of others
who who should not have an opinion on
these topics like there's no there is no
scenario in which you should be getting
your opinion about vaccine safety or or
climate change or
the war in Ukraine or anything else that
we might want to talk about from Candace
Owens right it's just like it like like
she she's not a relevant expert on any
of those topics and what's more she
doesn't seem to care right and and she's
living in a culture that has had that
has
Amplified that not carrying into a
business model an effective business
model right so it's just it's um and
that there's something very trumpy and
about
rabbits it's kind of bizarre because I
think we're all in agreement here the
experts whether they're the political
experts or the science experts or the
cult whatever experts have gotten almost
everything wrong lately so there are
reasons that people turn to other normal
people
yeah yeah first of all I just want to
say I I still you know really like Sam
and he has a fantastic meditation app
that I use every day I think he's done
incredible work in extracting the
greatest kind of spiritual wisdom from
the East you know in his time when he
was in India and bringing that to the
West uh bringing traditional you know
Buddhist and Hindu practices and kind of
in a universal uh message on his waking
up app but all of that aside
he just miserably failed in my opinion
and I've told him that and we've
privately corresponded at Great length
about these things and to some success
but to some failure although I do have
uh you know I honestly do have hope for
him because as more and more information
comes out um it's going to be very very
hard to uh defend his positions that
he's taken in the past but you know Sam
says that we shouldn't be listening to
people like Candace Owens or others on
vaccine safety and vaccine efficacy but
at the height of of 2021 in the summer
when vaccines were rolled out on his
podcast he was saying the case for
getting vaccinated is absolutely
clear-cut everybody should be getting
this thing right away as soon as
possible and I think one thing uh listen
to that clip that I think is a mistake
that Sam makes and a lot of people make
um there's on one side there are facts
that are difficult to know like the way
you learn about those facts is by debate
scientific debate among people who have
some expertise sometimes even people who
don't look to have the relevant
expertise have important things to say
about facts on on the other side you
have values about what to do with those
facts uh like someone like Sam Harris
has his values and he has his knowledge
his view of facts he's entitled to them
someone like Candace Owens has her her
knowledge uh about about the about the
facts and also her her values I think
are quite at odds with with uh with
someone like Sam Harris you combine
those together and you may have a very
different opinion about what to do about
about you know X Y or Z it doesn't
that's not misinformation that's just
that's just how humans like make action
make decisions is by a combining facts
with their values and then then making
recommendations